Hello and welcome to the Rawkode Academy and
today's episode of Rawkode Live. I'm your host,
David Flanagan. Although, of course, you'll know me
as Rawkode across the internets.
Before we begin on today's session, taking a
look at Docker Compose v two, I would
encourage you to like, share, comment, subscribe
this video, other videos, the channel, all of
the bits in between. This helps other people
find the content and makes YouTube's algorithm like
me a little bit more.
We also have a membership program available at
the academy with an InfloxDB course and flight.
Feel free to check out the membership options
on Rawkode.live.
And if you wanna come and chat with
over 500 other Docker Kubernetes cloud native
developers and technologists, then come and join us
on the Discord at Rawkode.chat.
Alright. Housekeeping over. Let's jump over to introduce
Brett Fisher, who needs no introduction, but I'm
gonna give you a little one anyway.
Brett Fisher is the author of Docker Mastery
and
has a really cool channel called Brett Brett
Fisher, Docker, and DevOps, A channel that I'm
sure we've all seen lots of times, love
the content, and I'm very excited to have
you on the show today. So hey, Brett.
How are you?
Glad to be here, David.
It's been too long. We haven't I don't
know why we haven't done this earlier, but
not lack not to the lack of your
trying.
I am bad at follow-up, so I'm excited
to finally do this. Well, it's good that
we get to spend a little bit of
time together today and talk about Docker Compose
and anything else that pops up as we
go. So, yeah, I'm really excited.
Give you a little introduction, but to anyone
that's watching that is not familiar, do you
wanna just follow-up with who you are and
a little bit more information if you will?
Yes.
Sure. I
I've been in IT for almost thirty years,
so I'm getting pretty old. I got the
the gray hair thing going on.
And
I like to say I've been I was
doing DevOps before it was called DevOps because
we didn't know what to call it. Right?
It was just kind of
optimizing
and
automating as many things as we could. Of
course, that was the dark days of the
the February when it was everything was hard
to do.
And about a year into Docker existing,
I realized it was like the next wave
of tech. I just was convinced that it
was going to be everywhere and everyone was
gonna use it. And instead of being
sort of an an implementer of change, I
wanted to be a part of it. I
wanted to, like, influence it, and
and I love teaching. I love sharing with
others. No matter what job or role I'm
in in an organization, I'm always trying to
share information and learn from others and collaborate.
So
I did that. And then eventually, I I
created a course. I got to be a
Docker captain. They
gave me that title because I wouldn't shut
up about it, and I wouldn't stop bugging
them.
And then, you know, here we are today.
I've got
a team of people that help me manage
over a quarter of a million people in
a 80
some countries on my courses.
Thousands of people every month in there doing
that, and it's really it's fun. It's exciting.
I also still do consulting. So I'm still
a DevOps consultant because I like to do
too many things all at once. And so
I'm always learning I'm always trying to learn
new stuff, especially in the real world.
I think like a lot of us,
you know, I teach what I know and
I teach what I've done.
So it's hard for me to just approach
a topic purely for educational purposes. I really
wanna get my hands on and all that
stuff. So, I'm always like, this year, if
you've been on if you've my live show,
I won't show up about things like GitHub
Actions and GitOps and,
automation essentially of all things
in the DevOps space or even more into
the ops space. But I I come at
this a little bit different too because I
I'm an ops guy
that lives in a developer world. And a
lot of times,
my perspective is slightly skewed from developer tooling
because I'm coming at it from that operator
mindset.
But it's great because I get to hang
out with a lot people that have different
views than me, it's that's always a lot
of fun. Awesome.
Thank you for sharing all that.
I'm gonna throw a random question that, you
know, just since you early prediction of Docker
being a game changing technology.
Like
let's remove Docker from the equation. Let's remove
Kubernetes from the occasion. What's that next big
one? Is there anything you could add on
that you're you're playing with or you think
it's gonna be really cool in the next
five years?
Yeah. It's one I
don't know. It could be a lot of
things. Like, you could I I have a
hard time figuring out what would be as
big, and it's not so much Docker the
tool. Right? Like to me, what I saw
was that what I talk about is the
three big innovations of containers. It was, and
Docker kinda got them all right to begin
with, the idea of the image format, right?
So like those tarball layered
read only sort of SHA hashed objects that
you can send around and easily transfer from
machine to machine in a reproducible format. Like,
that was fantastic because we'd had NPM and
Gems and App and Git and all these
other package managers and things, but they were
always ecosystem focused. And so that
that was great. And then they made a
a really easy tool to run it, as
we all know, the Docker command line, and
then the registry to link them all together,
right, which which is now becoming the generic
object store. And we're storing Helm charts in
there and all sorts of other manifests and
objects and things, and becoming like that central
hub of artifacts that you get throughout your
organization. So I
almost feel like it was three it was
a trifecta of great ideas that all landed
at the perfect time.
What the next one is,
some people might say serverless. I feel like
serverless is just a part of containers,
and I don't think that the hardest thing
for me with serverless is that it requires
greenfields, so I I don't think that that's
really a wave of, like, it's gonna hit
us and then knock us knock us on
the floor and give us a a big
surprise like Docker did, you know?
Some some of it, I think, I feel
like might be the the dawn of ARM
computing everywhere, even though we've had ARM forever
and there's a lot of people that are
on that bad wagon, Right? Alex Ellis is
one of the big
cloud native advocates of of ARM. I feel
like the fact that
the fact that Apple has finally got in
the game and doubled down by saying everything
we do is gonna be ARM starting next
year. Yep. It's forcing Microsoft's hand, right? It's
focusing
every other laptop or consumer
grade
PC tech company to adjust to that new
reality of thin and light, better battery life,
longer lasting.
But I think the real difference there is
that it's going to make every developer a
multiplatform developer. Like, eventually,
we will all either be on a machine
that's not the machine that our server platform
is running, so we now have to develop
on a different platform,
or
we're going to realize the benefits that we
if you've seen the AWS Graviton processors and
some of these things coming out where the
indeed, we're getting 40 plus percent
price to performance savings
on servers simply by switching architecture.
And so if that takes place first, then
us as developers and operators
will be on a platform that the server
is a different platform than what we're on
because maybe we're still on an Intel machine.
So the point there is that suddenly every
developer that for the last thirty years hasn't
really had to care unless you're in an
edge case or you're making embedded hardware or
you're you know, which obviously there's lots of
people that do that. But for the rest
of us that are just normal lives as
Intel people, we've never had to care. And
I I think that making developers
educated about multiplatform is really, I think, gonna
provide a lot of long term benefits for
the ecosystem and allow us to do cross
platform things, give people choice and all that
stuff. So it that it doesn't sound as
exciting though,
but it is to me. Because I I
can nerd out on the hardware or the
software all day long, so Awesome.
There are really a couple of things there.
Like, you mentioned
well, how old is Docker now? Right? Seven,
eight years?
Eight. Eight We we passed did we pass
seven or past eight? Shoot, I can't remember.
2013. Okay. So we've got a whole
industry of developers with less than eight years
experience. So maybe I've just always known Docker
as a deployment mechanism.
And you know, I I've been doing this
for twenty years. You said you bailed West
period like you said of the early two
thousands where deployment was
a that was weird.
I am running a beta version of ECAM
as we're about to find out today. However,
yeah, there's that whole Wild West period where
I know I won't put words in your
mouth, but deployment for me in 02/2002, '2
thousand and '3 was tearing up a bunch
of files or doing a git pull on
our production server and doing the build process
on the production server under a directory that
was called dot live, moving the old one
to dot back and then there was dot
back with a date timestamp.
There's just so many people have never dealt
with that. So I think Docker, you're right.
It's just perfect timing and those three different
tranches, there's three different problems that it solved.
I think we're just perfect together. In fact,
Docker always summarizes what builds ship and run.
Like, those are the three
things that they try to do really well.
Right. Yeah. I mean, Kubernetes is obviously taking
a lot of the oxygen out of the
room and it's and it's always neat and
exciting to play with new tech on it.
But I feel like it's just, it's, you
know, it's building on the shoulders of giants,
right? And those
three original
features, I think, are still today. Like, I'm
actually redoing some of the stuff in my
Docker Mastery course, and I'm sort of doubling
down on those three pillars
of image registry
runtime. And, like, if you understand those three
pillars, then you can kind of regardless of
whether you're using Docker or Kubernetes or Podman
or whatever, right, can sort of piece together
the workflow
of I gotta build it, I gotta get
it places, and then I gotta run it.
And I've kind of shaped a lot of
my storytelling
around those things, because they really haven't changed,
right? We've standardized, which is great. We've got
formats now that everybody's agreeing on, and all
the tools can center around it. And so
sometimes I think like,
what's the next thing that will be so
universal and it will be so loved that
it will become a standard
that everyone will adopt in the industry? And
I I don't know, man. Like, that's I
really have a good answer for that one
yet. Alright. No worries. But why don't we
go back to something else that you said
and then we'll get hands on with this
Docker Compose malarkey stuff. Right? You mentioned that
Yeah. You know, multi architectures, the machine that
you develop against may not be the machine
that you're deploying to. I think with the
advent of Kubernetes and microservices distributed systems, that's
what we're seeing is that people rarely
are developing locally, at least maybe not on
a full application level anyway,
which tend to ties in nicely to what
we're talking about today with with Docker Compose.
So we we posed this as a, should
we still be using Docker Compose for local
development?
Is there a one word answer there that
you want us to throw out? Or are
we gonna do this through example? Well,
I mean, if you've if you've watched any
of my stuff or taken any of my
courses, you'll know that I'm probably gonna say
yes because I'm
I'm a big believer in,
like, streamlining workflow, minimalism.
I am a fan of trying to create
server like infrastructure locally, but to a point.
Like, Kelsey Kelsey
Hightower is famous for, like, at least in
my my mind, he's famous for
saying, I don't run Docker locally. I just
build Go apps, and then they get put
into containers for servers. Right?
I think he might have said that on
my show one time. And
I took that to heart because
as your team
gets more efficient and you move to more
modern languages and tooling,
you may be able you may have less
need for containers locally.
And then what I see is the opposite
happening some places where people are going all
in on Kubernetes and making that their local
development environment or a remote development environment because
if you've ever tried to run it locally,
you know that it will burn down your
CPUs and your lap if if you sit
your laptop on your lap Mhmm. With, like,
yeah, with, like, steady steady three to 5%
CPU usage. Even on on keys, k three
s,
there is just a natural
loop that's happening in the background that's gonna
eat up cycles.
So and the reality is Kubernetes was never
designed to run for a developer laptop. That
was not original scope of the project at
all, but a lot of people are making
it work there. And so I always look
at say, well,
to have to know Kubernetes to simply develop
in a container
is a lot, right? Yep. And
I'm always working I spend a lot of
time working with new people
because of my courses, so I'm working with
people that are still relatively
new to containers, adopting containers and Kubernetes.
And so I very much sympathize with the
minimalist approach to
just get me the containers I need, just
spin them up with a one line command,
and don't make me start a bunch of
other things and
and have to know
five different other tools before I can even
start committing code. Right?
So Compose can do that.
Other
tools, not so much. And Compose is kinda
universal. I think Docker brags about 800,000
YAML files on GitHub for Docker Compose.
So they
they use that as sort of a bragging
rights of, yeah, yeah, there's lots of Compose
files out there. A lot of people are
using it. Yeah.
So,
yeah, that's just Spoiler alert, we're gonna talk
about Compose as a dev tool. We can
talk about comparing it to others, although I'm
not an expert on all of them, because
there's tons of there's tons of ideas out
there for how to create a container based
development environment. Oh, yeah. Definitely. Then maybe You
might have dimmed someone on your show here.
Yeah. I think I can maybe contrast some
things as we go if if we feel
it's pertinent. But we do have an interesting
comment in the chat from the studio there.
If you ask Brett Swarm or Kubernetes, he
will say Swarm.
Are you still back in Swarm?
No. No. No. See well, CJ's teasing me.
Yeah.
Hello, CJ.
Yeah. I mean, I I was one of
the last holdouts for Swarm.
I'm not saying it's a bad tool,
and I still use it actually, I still
use it to run some APIs on the
Internet for Slack integrations and stuff like that
because I can you know, it
it works with anything. I don't have to
rewrite stuff into a serverless function or something,
and I can just run some silly little
web API on a DigitalOcean server. Of course,
now we have all these, you know, automated
Kubernetes
systems that spin it up and tear it
down and all that stuff, so I I
could technically do that. But I've had swarms
there for
four or five years, and they just keep
on running. But, yeah, no. I mean,
Swarm was just sort of the casualty of
everyone wanted one tool instead of two, which
I'm a big fan of having more than
one option.
I I I love that Nomad as a
project is still a thing so that we
get some different ideas in the ecosystem around
running clusters of containers and that Kubernetes isn't
the only thing in existence.
But, yeah, I I don't recommend Swarm to
any business anymore. It's more for, like, hobby
projects or,
you know, Docker's still building it into the
container run or to the runtime, and I
I keep asking, and they keep saying they're
still gonna ship it, but they don't have
any developers currently working on it. So, Marantis,
the company that Docker split into,
basically, they Marantis bought most of Docker's
employees as well as their
closed sourced software.
They did that a couple years ago, and
there's they still have a couple of people
working on it and building they're actually working
on adding
CSI support from Kubernetes for storage because one
of the the weak weak links in Swarm
is and Docker in general is the plug
in support for other volumes besides local volumes.
And
they're looking to just sort of adopt the
CSI pattern so that people can write
very similar wrappers or something around the the
existing CSI drivers for Kubernetes, and then they'll
just work in Docker and Swarm. But we're
we're still waiting on that PR to drop.
They're working on a bunch of them, actually.
I
was actually Team Swarm as well, and I
got dragged away kicking and screaming
just as the industry kind of insulated Kubernetes
against my will as well, however. Yeah.
And as an ops guy, I want to
think I'm I'm an ops guy who always
wants things to be simpler, and
the thing about Swarm that really spoke to
me was like, man, if things could be
this simple,
how more productive would we all be? Like,
how amazing could it be to have developers
actually do more
like, have more insight and be able to
do things without feeling so handicapped around
infrastructure
and being,
you know,
cut out of the infrastructure game. Right? Because
a lot of times there's a saying that
I learned years ago called the the
ops mafia or the IT mafia,
which is to say that
IT, traditional IT and ops, tends to be
a barrier for developers to get their stuff
onto servers and into production.
And until you get to a really
well oiled DevOps machine,
that still tends to be the case in
a lot of organizations. And I'm a part
of that problem. I'm a part of those
people that put in security requirements and, you
know, all these infrastructure requirements of you have
to write all this YAML and do all
these things and do all these scans and
all this stuff.
And it was kind of like, man, if
Docker could iterate enough
on this idea, they might have a tool
that could be presented
and let people just get their job done,
right? And and the rest of it
all gets handled for them. And there's actually
still an idea out there, not that we're
gonna go down these rabbit holes. It's gonna
happen. But there is this idea that Docker's
sort of riffing on for
if you build we'll get into this with
Docker Compose v two, but you can build
Compose v two today and have it deploy
to a Kubernetes cluster using the Compose YAML.
And so what if the idea eventually was
the developer writes Compose YAML
and then the ops layers on their manifests
or their helm charts or whatever they need
for the ops focused stuff,
And there's just enough of an overlap that
you don't you're not forcing developers to write,
you know, Helm charts and customize,
but they can stick with YAML
simple in well, it's all YAML, but simple
YAML in the Compose format with maybe a
little bit of extras for things like Ingress.
So there's an idea floating around about how
Compose could be that bridge because if you
go back to the original Kubernetes
goals of the project and the founders,
a lot of them talk about how they
never intended for the manifest YAML to be
the interface
for developers to deploy applications.
They were always expecting something else,
and that else
has attempted
a hundred times, at least a hundred times,
in different projects like we see with Customize
and Helm, and there's just a ton of
other ways to do it,
where you're describing your application and all the
parts of it in a way that Kubernetes
can understand and deploy.
A whole sync working on that and have
been working on it for for years now.
Yeah.
It's a difficult spec for them to to
anyone to write, really. Yeah. And you have
to get like, you you have to take
a lot of considerations into account, and then
you and then you have to get buy
in from the community, right? So you have
to
you have to get
enough people on board that it looks like
this could be a winner, right? That's kind
like with Helm, right? Helm isn't always the
right tool, but it it looks like the
winner. So we all gravitate to that first
even though it maybe isn't the right tool
for every job or the easiest tool for
every job.
And I'm kind of holding out for Compose.
So I was so if I take my
Swarm fan base, if I take my Swarm
fandom and I apply it to just the
Compose format and the Compose
workflow,
there might be a day where you can
do a Docker Compose
deploy,
and it applies
to a Kubernetes cluster,
layers on some other things, and the developer
and the operator can still exist
and not step on each other's toes but
not have to know everything about everyone else's
job, which
is kind of one of the things that
DevOps brought to the forefront, but also that
one of the biggest stumbling blocks I find
with teams, right, is that they now have
to learn everyone else's stuff. Like, can I
just focus on the things that I need
to know instead of everything else?
That's a real big challenge, I think, for
companies, which is why us Kubernetes trainers are
always training people on Kubernetes because
they now all of a sudden, have to
know it just to deploy their container app
when they previously didn't have to know it.
Yeah. I I did Kubernetes workshop at conferences,
at least before COVID anyway, and I'm always
surprised that the workshop just keep getting busier
and busier all the time. There's just always
that influx of new people trying to learn
the basics of Kubernetes and and even containers
and Docker. Like, it's just and it's such
a difficult space to education in, so people
should definitely check out your courses.
We got a question there that I think
correlates
quite nicely to what you were just talking
about there with Compose files and applying them
to Kubernetes. But Yanis asks,
Compose versus Docker Stack
for local dev. Docker Stack attempted to do
that
deployment of a Compose to Kubernetes cluster, or
am I mistaken?
Yeah. Docker stack was like the production version
of Compose. So that's a great question. Let's
back up a second. So what we're talking
about are two potentially different things.
There's a composed file format,
which both Docker Swarm, aka Docker Stacks,
and Docker Compose, the command line tool, those
both share that Compose spec.
There's
two different tools there, right? There's two different
purposes. So Docker Compose, the command line, which
we're talking about today,
that is optimized for local development workflow. And
so whenever I teach developers, whenever I train
consulting clients that I'm working with, it's always
about let's get everyone all in on the
Docker
Compose command line as their developer tool because
most of these people that are coming into
containers are not, like, I don't advise learning
Kubernetes as the first thing you're doing in
containers, right? So I usually start them with
Docker and we get the
typical onboarding is getting their Docker files and
whatnot.
And then
once they can get the parts of that
working in Docker, we say, okay, now let's
do Docker Compose to describe your application and
all the things about it in a very
relatively simple YAML file.
And
then when they realize they can do a
Docker Compose up and a Docker Compose down
and that spins up entire environments based on
the directory it's in, they kinda get that
light bulb. You can see it switch on
in their head, and they learn, okay, this
is way easier than what I was doing
before.
And a lot of people even will avoid
Compose or just not realize the power of
it, and they'll write shell scripts around Docker
commands. Well, that's the entire point of Docker
Compose is to avoid
Its whole purpose is to allow you to
avoid shell scripts and other developer tooling and
just focus on writing a few YAML files
that describe your app that really I look
at as almost like a predecessor to describing
it in manifest, which are much more verbose
and complicated.
So
the long answer to that question
great question, by the way, thank you is
a stack is exclusively
for Swarm, and Swarm is not a developer
tool.
So
some of the things that you can do
with Docker Compose, like Docker Compose PS and,
like, some of these other command lines that
we'll get into, you can't really do that
easily in Swarm, and it takes more work.
And Swarm really concerns itself with, like, uptime
and availability and health checks
and rolling updates and stuff like that where
Compose, Docker Compose, the command line tool has
none of that, right, because it's really more
about the developer experience. So we'll we'll talk
about how, like, Docker Compose has things like
depends on that allows you to start things
up in order, whereas Swarm and Kubernetes aren't
really about that. That's, like, production infrastructure. You
have to deal
with that in a different manner. But local
development, usually, you don't want your web server
bouncing for five minutes while your your SQL
server's ingesting content. So so you want you
you wanna optimize your local startup. You wanna
make it really simple with pretty colors and
local commands and status commands and stuff like
that, and that's really what the Docker Compose
command line tool is all about. It just
so happens that the two of them share
the same file format. So,
I mean, we're gonna get to the hands
on actually writing and working with Compose in
just a minute to anyone that's getting worried
that we're now nearly thirty minutes in and
we're still talking. But
that's one of the reasons I still use
Docker Compose format
2.3 or 2.4
because of the health check and being able
to orchestrate the startup of the containers.
But that was removed in subsequent versions. Is
is that now working again, out of curiosity?
Sorry. Was I was looking at the chat.
Which which feature?
Yeah. So in Docker Compose, always used version
2.4,
I think it is, because it allowed you
to see
it depends on service
healthy, service start eat, and actually orchestrate. Because
when you spend something up in development, it's
very different to the production environment where you
are happy for things to flap while things
are again reconciled or whatever. But in development,
like you said, I want to be able
to start my MySQL,
Postgres, import,
and then have my web application container start
up because it's going to do some sort
of seed or database reconciliation.
And I do need that ability, but I
believe they removed
the dependencies in later versions were just
start this container first and that's it because
Yeah. Of something with version three.
Yeah.
And I'm gonna answer your that's a great
question. I'm gonna answer yours and
Roger Leanne's
question on does Compose v three support limits
like in prox?
So
the so,
again, when we're talking about Docker Compose, the
command line tool, not Swarm,
we no longer have Compose file versions. So
the spec,
which what we can I can put I'm
actually gonna put URLs in chat?
So there is now a Compose spec, and
it's on a single markdown document.
I'm not sure if it'll let me post
URLs. Oh, yep. Okay. It should be alright.
And
so if you just go to, like, github.com/composespec/composespec,
there's a spec in
there. And what Docker did a couple years
ago
was they announced that basically
they made the they made the specification,
we can call it an API spec, but
a specification for how you use Compose.
Again,
Compose
is too many different things to many different
people, but when it comes to this API
spec,
they formalize, which we never really had that
before, that the Compose file version that we
all typed version colon two and version colon
three, whatever, that was an implementation of the
spec that they had never really
formalized. So they formalized the spec, and then
they said, okay, now it's gonna be up
to the tool to implement
whatever features of the spec that they want,
but we're not gonna version the spec.
So how this works is we're
gonna talk today about Compose v two, and
Compose v two is really a rewrite of
the whole Compose command line tool into Golang
away from Python. They're integrating it as a
Docker plugin right into the Docker tool. Lots
of advantages.
But one of the big things about it
is that both that and the now legacy
tool, is Docker Compose,
now all follow in their latest versions the
Compose spec, which means no more versions. So
you don't have to worry about version two
dot four. Other people don't have to worry
about version three versus version two. Like, of
that matters. The Compose spec is a superset
of all of that and it includes all
those features and then new ones. And so
it's now up to the tool to look
at the YAML and decide how it's gonna
implement
all the features and whether it's whether it
supports the deploy feature or the depends on
feature
or the health check feature. That's gonna now
be up to the tool.
You could say that Swarm is a tool
implementation.
Docker Compose command line tools is is a
Compose spec implementation.
And there's lots of other ones, like Compose
with a k, which is a Kubernetes tool
for turning your
Compose with a CEML into Kubernetes manifest.
That tool is also an implementation.
AWS has an implementation for ECS. Like, there's
a bunch of implementations now
of this spec, and what's important for us
is, in today's context, is that
the new version two of the Docker command
line Compose tool implements that brand that, well,
almost brand new spec,
and you don't you and I don't have
to ever worry about those versions anymore. Now,
Swarm,
just
to follow-up for those people that are talking
about Swarm, Swarm doesn't yet implement this new
Compose spec.
So it still requires
you to put in like version three dot
eight or whatever the, I think three dot
eight or three dot nine is the newest
version there.
And if we went down the history road
for a minute, version two was always kinda
meant for local Docker Compose command line use,
and version three was always meant for Swarm,
And they never really fully fleshed out adding
all the version two features to version three.
It wasn't like they didn't deprecate anything, which
was a rumor on the internet. They just
didn't really we weren't really ever sure how
to implement depends on in a cluster. So
they never really finished
adopting that
organization
that's required in order to do depends on
across many servers, right? They never really implemented
that in Swarm, and so that was really
the reason version three never adopted. And I
and I'm like you, I love the depends
on feature.
We can actually go through an example and
talk about it because a lot of people
don't know that it exists and it's pretty
awesome.
Alright. Awesome.
Alright. We'll just quickly cover some of the
comments and then we're gonna go over to
the screen share and we're gonna start playing
with some of this new goodness. So
said said v three still has health checks.
Yes. But it depends on functionality. It doesn't
support conditional
start thingies, which I'm hoping we're gonna play
with today.
APM asked us Docker Compose or for Podman.
Not really, but as Kevin has commented, there
is a Podman Compose. Feel free to check
out that project. I think it's on the
containers, git hub Com /
containersorganization.
Yeah. That's a good I'm I'm glad for
that because I had forgot what the answer
was. I knew that there was a way
to do it, but I I could remember
what it was at Podman. And
so I guess that would be we have
to look at it, but I guess we
could say that, hopefully, Podman Compose
is implementing the Compose spec.
So that way, we will start getting because
if were to dive
and nerd out in the Compose spec, there's
actually
a lot of interesting
ideas and things that
could be implemented in various tools in various
ways to allow us to all use this
simple YAML file format to do actually
more of the things that we don't think
Compose is for, right, like Ingress,
Well, more more advanced things than Ingress, but
I was gonna say storage, but storage is
kinda already in there with the drivers concept.
But that's what that's what we really haven't
seen a tool take to the next level
yet is
taking the Compose spec and turning it into
a production
ready
man almost like manifest light. Right?
And there is that ECS integration, like CJ
is mentioning,
and they have some new stuff in there
as well for Azure
ACI as well as AWS's ECS. So you
can you can either check out my channel
or Docker's channel.
People have shown about how you can use
Docker command line with this new new Compose
tool to not just deploy to Docker, but
also to deploy to clouds like an ECS
cluster or an ACI server inside of Azure.
So
Docker
a a side comment on this is that
a lot of people, when they think of
Docker in the old ways and how to
deploy it, we think of things like Docker
machine,
other tools for setting up Docker on a
server.
And since Docker is now focused as a
company, they're focused on developer tooling, they're not
trying to create servers anymore. In fact, they're
almost intentionally
going away
from being the
we do run times on your servers, so
build a bunch of servers and do our
stuff, right? Their approach is now,
hey, look, the clouds have all got their
APIs for how they wanna do container deployments,
and they all have different interesting ideas on
how to do that in various ways. So
now what we're seeing with this new Docker
Compose
CLI tool is it's using the Compose spec
to
allow you to deploy directly to those ideas
rather than, like, you know, we mentioned
Kubernetes directly
to the Kubernetes API
and then to something like ECS, which is
a different cloud API, and then something like
Azure
ACI, which is a different API. So now
Docker is you think about it, they're they're
they're adding integrations to integrate with cloud APIs,
not with their daemon,
which is
totally one eighty from, you know, the first
five years of Docker's life, six years of
Docker's life. It was all about the Docker
daemon is somewhere, you have the Docker command
line or the Compose command line, and you're
talking to that daemon on a TCP port.
And now, what they're really looking at this
is, well, we have that, and that's great,
but we're going our future is really in
integrations to clouds, and we're gonna use Compose
as the way to do that.
Alright. Awesome.
I think we should get you I think
we get your screen shared and we start
having some fun with this new Yeah. CLI
v two.
Too much talking, not enough doing.
No. It's
a good good conversation. I think it adds
a lot of context and people can understand
the history of these tools and and and
where it's going. I always think I'm always
amazed,
you know, the original Docker Compose written in
Python, I think, was maintained by one person
for, like, the last two or three years
of its existence. Yeah.
One
or two main people in there and, yeah.
Well, seeing it running Go with the spec
just brings a whole new lease of life
to it, which is really exciting. Yeah. There
was I mean,
there was a conference in Berlin, a Docker
conference called the Distributed
they only did it one time. It was
2016,
I think, maybe yeah, 2016,
in Berlin called the Distributed Computing Conference, and
it was right I
don't think it was KubeCon. It might have
just been, like, a Linux
Foundation conference, anyway, in Berlin.
And so everybody
was there, and
it was a really interesting conference because a
lot of the ideas that we're still seeing
implemented today in distributed computing and in Docker
were first there,
like distributed
storage, a lot of it distributed
storage that's connected to containers automatically.
Those are still things that are being fleshed
out. But one of them was we're gonna
rewrite Compose in Go, and then we're gonna
be able to
share libraries from Docker and Compose to use
the same underpinnings instead of two different languages
and two different libraries.
It's sad that it took this many years
to get there five years later,
but at least it's here. And it's it's
an opportunity because I think there's a lot
of edge cases around the Python. Like, most
people don't realize Docker Compose uses Pyinstaller,
so it actually it adds
two or three hundred milliseconds to every command
in terms of delay unless you're installing it
with PIP because it has to unpack
the binary,
run Python with the with the scripts, and
then do this stuff. And then, of course,
debugging when you get errors in Python is
always interesting.
So,
yeah, there's lots of good news here. In
fact, let me share my browser first because
let's just let's go over real quick for
those that aren't
savvy of how even how to get this
before I start demoing it.
I I don't think I can share I
don't think I can switch Windows. I think
I just have to stop and start.
But if the good news is is if
you are on
Docker desktop, you already have this. So this
new version is Docker Compose
instead of Docker Compose.
So it's a plugin sub command of Docker,
and if you have Docker Desktop, it comes
with it. You already have it. So just
start typing Docker Compose from now on, and
all your original commands work, and then there's
a bunch of new ones.
But they have their own repo, so instead
of it the old repo was github.com/docker/compose.
The new one is I'm gonna zoom in
a little bit so it's easier to read.
The new one is
Compose CLI, so Compose dash CLI.
And if you scroll down, you can find,
for Linux people, there are people that aren't
using maybe they're using a VM and they're
not using Docker desktop.
You can get install instructions there, which is
essentially
the newer instructions are essentially have Docker installed
and
download this plugin.
And there's a format for Docker plugins, and
they go in a subdirectory of your user
directory and all that stuff. So they they
get you set up and running,
and then you should be able to go
to your command line and do that. By
the way, I think I did I link
the spec? I think I already linked the
spec earlier.
But that this is the spec, which is
this very, very long single
markdown file.
I'll put the Compose CLI there in the
people.
But let's switch over and
man, this this this shares this is for
later feedback on Ecamm Live. This the sharing
screen button is right next to the hang
up button. It's super
super
Well, I thank you for not hanging up
on me. So Right. That would be awkward.
Okay. And that concludes today's episode.
So
you'll notice that when I do a Docker
Compose
version
so this is my old Python
runtime.
So you'll see, like, Docker Py, which is
technically the library
that Compose is wrapped around and then c
Python.
And so now if I do a Docker
Compose version,
it this is the Go binary that's running
from a subdirectory
of the plugins where all the Docker plugins
are at. And if you do a Docker
info,
you can see
in that info list,
you can see plugins that are installed in
your Docker. Some some of us may not
realize we've actually had plugins
for a while. If you're running Docker Desktop,
Docker Desktop will automatically add a scan. So
Docker space scan is which is from Snyk.
So it's like a Sneak plugin,
and then Buildx is the new
advanced builder for fancier and faster building of
your Docker images. So those are all plugins
already. So now we get this new one
Compose,
which they're they've been iterating through the release
clients lately and still squashing some bugs and
stuff like that. I tend to use it
every day. I've been do trying to do
it all year. Obviously, as it's matured, the
bugs have been less and less, and I
think I'm only tracking, like, one bug that
only happens every so often. So
then we we when we do those Docker
Compose
commands, if you're someone who's used Compose before,
if you just type Docker space Compose, you
see
all all the typical commands. Right? And most
people actually
when they use Compose, they use, like, two
we all know, like, the Docker Compose up
and the Docker Compose down. Those are probably
the first two that everyone learns, and they
might learn Docker Compose build, which builds all
the images that are inside of that one
Compose file, which is convenient.
But when you think of Compose, think of
it as I should never have to type
an actual Docker command without the Compose
because the Compose is designed for a project
mindset. So all of these commands
have the scope of whatever current Compose YAML
file you're using. So if I use if
I do a Docker Compose PS,
I will only see listed the containers that
are in my current project, not maybe other
containers that I got running somewhere else
on machine, my local machine, my server, whatever.
So that's one of the reasons I say
it's the developer friendly tool because a lot
of us may need to run multiple projects
at the same time if we're trying to
integrate two things together,
or maybe we don't wanna spin something down
while we go test something else.
And so these Compose commands are designed to
wrap
the Docker and sort of filter out anything
else in Docker that you're not dealing with
at the moment in your current directory.
And so a lot of people will be
surprised to find things like Docker Compose top,
Docker Compose. Now we have
we've had PS,
but now we have this new one, LS,
which actually gets us
if you have many projects or many directories
where you've done Docker Compose up, you can
now see a list of all those.
And so you because sometimes we we forget,
like we close some windows, we forget, oh,
man, I got Docker Compose running somewhere. I
don't remember which directory it's from, and it's
not super obvious
how to get back to them. But now
in any directory, you can just type Docker
Compose ls,
and it will just show you if you
have any Compose projects running anywhere on your
system. And I don't. Yeah. What typically would
happen to me is I'd run a Docker
Compose app and it would complain about the
port bindings, and I'd go, oh, I've left
something running somewhere.
Exactly.
And that's exactly when you would use a
Docker Compose OS. I do that all the
time as well.
If you have a Docker desktop GUI,
the GUI now actually has a lot of
this built in too. I'm not gonna show
it, but
the dashboard GUI now has a Compose, it's
Compose aware, so it will show you a
Compose project and allow you to see the
logs. You can start and stop it all
from inside the GUI in case you're more
of a GUI person.
But, yeah. So that's a really nice they
added that right up front when they started
working on the v two, and that was
a nice add in because
it was one of those things where you
hit it and you're like, well, how do
I deal with this problem? I do a
Docker
PS, and I see a whole bunch of
containers, but I don't know
where they are or how to stop. I
don't wanna have to manually stop each one
of them, especially if you're, like, a microservice
person. That would be a lot of pain.
So we
have all the other typicals. Like, you can
actually copy files in and out of your
Docker Compose services because remember, all these things
are services in Compose.
You can copy things in and out. You
can exec into these, and you don't have
to know the container name. So what I
see, one of the big mistakes I see
people using
is they'll create a Compose file, and I've
done this before I learned how this worked,
but they'll manually
assign container names. So there's a YAML value
that they'll put in their file that says
container name, and they'll
hard code the container names,
and that tells me that they're still using
the Docker command line. They're not using Compose
for everything,
because if you're using Compose for everything, like
exec,
ps, logs, kill, start, stop, restart, like all
these commands that are managing it, you're using
the Compose commands for the service name, not
the container name. Because again, you can have
a service with multiple containers,
which is why when you start up something
in Docker Compose, you will see like Docker
Compose,
you know, service name dash one, you know,
and then dash two and dash three if
you do multiple replicas.
And so it it can do that, but
if you assign it a hard coded container
value,
you can never spin up more than one
replica. It's kinda like having a Kubernetes pod
that's manually named and then you try to
spin up an exact named pod. You it
won't work in that same namespace.
So that same thing is happening here. One
of my biggest pet peeves, I think every
Docker tutorial and Compose store on on the
Internet has container name hard coded and there's
never a single good reasoning. And I always
say this to people at conferences as well.
There's not one single good reason for naming
a container.
Using
container underscore name, just remove it immediately
and it's it's never good.
It
I I don't even have to ask why
they do it because I I
have a feeling that they're doing it because
they
they don't realize
typing and talking talking at the same time,
by the way.
They they don't realize that whatever the command
they needed to use for that container name
probably existed in the Docker Compose command line
and it's probably easier.
Yeah. They're almost writing a shell script to
do something with that container and, yeah, there's
no need to, like, can work around it.
Right. Oh, I just realized
I wanna be using Vim today to make
it easier for screen sharing and
my Vim is in bright mode.
So,
we're in I do like the mode though
with the the flames on it. I'm not
sure how you've got that, but that is
it. Oh, this is this is
not my skill set. This is
SpaceVim.
So look up SpaceVim,
which is kinda like a Vim
installer packager manager. It's it's a and it
does all this stuff for you.
So,
like, if I just do this, it will
actually update
a 34
plugins that it manages,
including,
yeah, including my font,
all of the the stuff at the bottom.
Very cool. I like that. Probably shouldn't have
done that. I guess it's a variation of
the Space Max, which is the Emacs within
bindings, and now there's a SpaceVim, so
Yes. It's mostly it's it's got a large
community. It's mostly managed by one person, but
it's regularly
updated. I've been using it for years. I
used to use SPF 13, I think,
and it that kind of died a little
bit on the vine. Wasn't wasn't getting maintained.
I think so. I've using SPF I was
brave doing a live update. Yeah. Update your
plugins live. What could go wrong, Brett? Come
on. Yeah. I do it all the time.
No big deal.
It NeoVim or just Vem8? Do you know?
Is it what? Is it using NeoVim or
is it using Vem8?
It uses both.
And so sorry. For me, my my
a Vim command is just aliased to in
Vim.
So you can use either one, and it
will plug into both. It installs into both
by default.
It it use it uses your Vim RC
and all that stuff.
I also enable italics for local use because
I love italicized
comments and stuff. Well, there goes my productivity
for the rest of the week as I
explore switching IDE again. So thanks. I
had yeah. Right? Like, I I
you're not the first person to tell me
that, and I'm going to give you all
a URL for later so that we don't
spend the episode on this because it's a
it is a rabbit hole and I love
talking about it. Yeah. Let's just forget Compose.
Let's just play with your Vim sale for
the next thirty minutes. So
I'm gonna put in the chat brettfisher.com/shell.
So all of the things that I use
in my shell there, including italicized,
true font true true color fonts,
all that stuff is in there.
I'm actually going to
not use
the shell because I realized I love using
Versus Code, and I'm just going to do
that for today. So
where we make we made temp
Rawkode.
So I'm just gonna share that. That way,
I don't have to switch back and forth
between Windows.
This this thing doesn't I could share my
whole screen, but I'm on a four k.
So
it not that I couldn't share the whole
screen, but
it would be very small for everyone. So
let's just do
my new favorite editor, Versus Code.
Alright. So we're just gonna create a Compose
file, and then we're gonna run some things.
Do we have any questions in the audience
that we haven't addressed yet?
No. Just a confirmation that SpaceFim is
Spacemax inspired
and some love for the rendered corner power
lane prompt, which I think, yeah, was looking
pretty good.
We could I could also demo off
what's what's gonna happen during this demo is
I'm I'm demo demoing Copilot, GitHub Copilot because
it I am hooked on Copilot. I like,
now I don't turn off anymore. It's just
so it bleeds my mind.
Yeah. It's unbelievable.
It's a little weird. It's a sometimes
I had a friend on the show, and
we we kinda tried to beat it up
for DevOps purposes,
and it
so we just spent an hour.
I recorded, like, a week's worth of using
it and recorded a bunch of little weird
oddities, like, using it for markdown editing. It's
soup. It just starts writing
words for you based on your previous words,
and you can fill out a whole markdown
file in gibberish. That doesn't really make any
sense. It'll actually auto create links for you
that don't work to things that don't exist.
I I don't yeah. It's it's a little
wild wild west right now, but
Can you drag your Versus code window a
bit wider?
You're breaking my layout brick. Come on. Oh,
man.
It's always hard to figure out that the
right layout. There we go. There we go.
A little bit a little bit more? A
little bit more?
Yeah. You can go more. Yeah. There we
go. Oh, you're Yeah.
See how yeah. It's already it's already telling
me the wrong thing.
It doesn't know
Compose files.
Alright. So we got a comment from Paul
saying that Brett is posting links, but they
aren't appearing. Yeah. I'll just go check that
now. They might be held for review because
there are links and I
can fix that.
Yeah. Let me go check that. If you
make me, like, a commenter or whatever Yeah.
I think it auto works. If you have
all the chat stuff, the security stuff enabled
like I do.
I'm not gonna do that. I'm gonna do
NGINX.
So we're all familiar to this with this
standard
format and, like
stuff like that.
And then
my terminal.
So there is a Docker tool that you
can get for Versus Code. I don't even
have it showing up here, but you can
get a Docker plugin, which I highly recommend.
And it will it can do you can
see things in here
and do things like and you can actually
run Compose commands from the command palette.
But I'm just gonna use command line because
I think a lot of people that's what
they're used to experiencing, and they do that.
So
if I'm in this directory, then
do a Docker Compose PS.
But right away, you'll notice that it this
new one uses the new builder,
which the new builder can do things much
more concurrently,
and it's actually really smart. There's a ton
of advantages to it, but one of the
things it'll do is if you're using multistage
images, it won't build stages that you don't
need for your current target in case you're
someone who's in the multistage building. So that's
a nice thing is the new Docker Compose
will just use the new build kit by
default.
And so I did that. Docker
Compose PS now.
And you'll see that I'm gonna
hide the files.
We'll see that we've got two services running.
Right? So this is kind of just sort
of proof that
by the way, it's it's proof that it
works like the old one works. And I
can also just type in Docker Compose with
a dash and get the same you can
kinda compare the old and new formats. So
one of the things they've done with the
new command is they've sort of refreshed the
format. It now
it it
they they're fixing some of the old quirks
since they kinda had to rewrite everything.
So we'll see that. And then I can
do things like Docker. Most people don't realize
you can do Docker Compose top,
the next, and that will show me the
processes running inside of that particular service.
So I can do that without even having
to go inside it.
I can pause things, stop things.
So, like, the workflow that most people, if
they're not familiar with it, you do Docker
Compose up to start everything up. You do
the Docker Compose down at the end of
your day to stop it all except for
deleting volumes.
And then you can do things like Docker
Compose pause while you go to lunch, and
it'll let your CPUs calm down because it'll
just sort of freeze the CPU but won't
stop the containers. You can also do stop,
start, restart. So those are all the common
commands.
But I think the value of a particular
demo that we wanna talk about, because we
talked about that depends on and
how that works,
is
to talk about two things, really, two major
things that most people don't know about that
would probably help their workflow in Compose, and
that's one talking about your depends on example,
and the other one is talking about
profiles.
And profiles,
for those of us that are getting real
world Compose files that are getting very large,
maybe we have dozens of services in there
or just a dozen or even just five,
you may not wanna spin those all up
at all at the same time. So profiles
is a new feature in the Compose spec
that the new Docker Compose tool now implements
that allows you to add a service line,
and you can basically tag your services and
then bring them up and down in groups
based on this tag,
which allows you to do things like
maybe you have a startup script that seeds
your database and does a bunch of things,
and you only wanna run that once. Well,
you can now do that by specifying a
separate service,
and
you can run it as a one off,
but it'll use all the Compose stuff. So
it won't always run it unless you specifically
run that profile.
Other things you can do is maybe if
you're a developer on a larger team,
maybe you're the front end developer, but the
file the Compose file's written for everyone. So
it has the API back end, it has
the database, it has the worker jobs, but
you're really just the front end person and
maybe you're using React.
And you really only need the you know,
you don't need the worker or all this
other stuff in the background. You really just
need the API and the database. So you
can now use profiles so that you can
now
You don't have to sit there and manipulate
each individual service, like just doing the Docker
Compose up of a specific service. You can
now specify a group of services by tagging
them. That's awesome. I've
lost track of how many make files I've
had to write. This spins up just the
right amount of services for what I was
doing or even to spin up a
service which normally has replica zero, but you're
just trying to run a single command, like
the database migrations and stuff. Yeah. Yeah. That's
nice. I like the details. And
that's the thing, right?
And Docker's still trying to iterate on this
stuff, so they've got some ideas around how
to even make take this further for one
off tasks. I think, really,
one of the things that interrupts developer workflow
is that we're all getting to the point
where we're all starting to have common tooling,
right? So we're all starting to learn Docker.
We all know some basics of Docker Compose.
Maybe some of us are saying that
basic kubectl commands are there, but then every
team seems to have these shell scripts and
make files and other
utilities
that are part of their workflow for local
use,
and
I'm gonna say I'm just gonna say watch
this space because I think Docker is trying
to figure this out a little bit better
using this new Compose syntax, maybe adding some
more features in the future.
But I have another repo
that I'm gonna I'm gonna steal some examples
so that we don't have to manually watch
me type all this,
which, you know, I'm sure that's super exciting
for everyone.
So I'm going to throw in
something like this.
Let's pretend that these servers, which they don't
really, but let's pretend that these servers depend
on a database
because, obviously, these are just standard NGINX servers.
Yep. But the Postgres server, if I throw
it in and I just launch it,
it actually now that think about it, this
won't actually work because it needs a password
nowadays, so my example's already out of date.
But one of the things that you wanna
do in these files now, and what we're
gonna
I'm gonna
not bury the lead, and we're just gonna
add the depends on.
Can also change that variable
for the the password if you wish as
well. I think it's just postgres underscore password
or postgres underscore password
to get it to start healthily.
Look at that. With that.
Yeah.
That's that's
GitHub Copilot
in action right there. Alright. So let's assume
that actually works.
So up here, so there's two parts to
this puzzle, and what we're trying to solve
is what you mentioned earlier, is I want
I don't want my front end app to
constantly bounce every time I do a Docker
Compose up because it's waiting on the database
to start.
Well, in Compose v two, like you were
saying sorry. Not Compose v two. That's that
not Compose command line v two, but in
the Compose file
version. Back in the day, we would type
version
two dot four. Right? And that would only
work with the local Docker command line tool,
would not work with Swarm, which is fine,
but it would allow us to use this
depends on,
but most people didn't know about this.
They didn't realize that they
could extend the depends on to not just
say depends on DB, because most people would
do this. They would not have this line,
right?
It would not have that line. They would
just have the depends on DB,
and then they would realize that it doesn't
really wait for the database to be ready.
It just starts the database first so that
the DNS is available. Yep. And so then
the app would still crash because it's still
waiting on the database to start or whatever.
But in
like two dot two or something, they added
this feature years ago that there's two different
conditions
here. You can say condition start or condition
service healthy. And what we want is service
healthy, which will use the Docker health check,
and then we add the health check. So
that's what I've done down here.
And if you go looking for
Docker, if you just Google GitHub Docker library
health check, those four words. Someone will probably
find it and put it in chat. Docker
has a library of sample
health checks for almost all the common open
source database technologies. So Redis,
Postgres, MySQL,
I'm not sure if Elasticsearch is in there,
but they have other stuff, MemQ, something like
that.
And they will
they will give you this example of how
to add a health check to a container
really easy so that you don't have to
make a custom image or anything like that
because you don't wanna have to do that.
And then what happens is now when this
starts up, and by the way, that's
it's the
here.
So if I do that and I go
back,
Docker Compose up.
Oh, right, I took the version out.
So we don't want that version anymore because
now we're on Compose spec. So basically,
if
you've been around five years, you know that
the version one of the spec that we
all were using way back in the very
early days of Compose, before we was even
called Compose, that was there was no version
for that.
But now the tooling, if there is no
version listed here, assumes you're using the latest
version of Compose spec, not the old, old,
old v one from, like, 2015.
So that that like, most people probably wouldn't
even think about that, but
it's smart enough to know the difference. So
if I do a Docker Compose up here,
it now recognizes that it needs to load
a database because I have set the depends
on.
Well, I've just set up for everything, so
it's gonna start it all. But
it's going to hopefully start that postgres correctly,
and then
it's going to wait
until the database
Ta da.
Yeah.
So you notice that little pause there because
I do this on NGINX one. Didn't give
NGINX one what it depends on, but I
did for NGINX two.
And
some of these examples, by the way, I'm
just gonna put another link,
are from a DockerCon twenty nineteen talk I
did.
I'll put this in chat for everyone.
So some of those examples are in there
where I show off how to use depends
on. Ignore the part of that video if
you watch it about it needing version two
because obviously in 2019,
we still needed the version two file format,
but now we don't.
So yeah. So ta da, that's the demo
of that one. Now I would do that
on everything in a Compose file. If I'm
on a real team making a real app,
I would have depends on everywhere because
what I would do is my so my
front end developer,
I would tell them, hey. When you do
Docker Compose up,
you're probably gonna wanna use Docker Compose up
of just your front end app.
And so now
it's gonna be smart enough to find all
the other services that it's
depending on, and it will start them first,
wait for them to start, and then you
can actually have multi chain sort of startup
order where you the database then starts, then
the API starts, then the front end starts.
And so you and with me, I actually
have another demo
that uses
I use most apps nowadays all require SSL.
And when you're dealing with cores and other
front end issues, you usually wanna develop with
SSL as well. So I have another repo,
if you just go to my GitHub,
that's called Compose TLS Dev
Proxy or something like that. And it basically
auto creates a self signed certificate or even
less encrypt signed certificate,
uses traffic,
and puts it all in your Docker Compose
file so that you can have a boilerplate
TLS wrapper
around every one of your web apps without
having to customize it for every web app.
And one of the things you do with
that in Compose is that you set it
all in the depends on so that essentially
what you're saying is all my front end
apps depend on the proxy to start first
as well as the database.
And so now you get this wonderful startup
order and your front end team, your back
end team, they can all just specify the
one thing they wanna work on when they
do the Docker Compose up command. In this
case, I'm just wanting to start NGINX.
And the Compose is now intelligent
and aware
of how things are healthy or not,
and you get this wonderful startup order. And
then your team will love you, right? If
you write this for your team and give
this to them
if you now do a Docker Compose PS,
you'll also notice that oh, they've all exited
because I did a
up
Now
they're gonna stay running in the background.
Detached.
And as soon as that's done,
if I do the PS again,
you'll actually see healthy there. So we get
this little extra information of maybe why things
never started because if your back end app
doesn't start correctly, you're still sitting there waiting
and waiting on the front end container to
start. You're like, why doesn't this thing start?
Well,
eventually, there'll be a time out, and it'll
just not try anymore. But you'll you can
see this as a indicator
for maybe why your your depends on doesn't
work.
Nice. Any questions in the audience?
Yeah. If anyone has any questions, just drop
them into the comments, and I'll read them
on to Brett as we kind of progress
through this.
Yeah. But it's it's it's nice just to
see those conditions working. I use them heavily,
and we'd go to conferences and tell people
never to use v three. It's only for
swarm, and I hate it. It's awful. I
don't like it. Use this one. And people
kept moaning at me saying, don't tell us
to use old versions or downgrade. And I'm
like, it's not a downgrade. It's a different
use case. Yeah. And I had this big
massive rant with so many people,
and now it just works. And I I
actually
I've not followed the Compose spec. I haven't
used the new Docker subcommand plug in Compose,
so I'm really, really happy to see that
working. Yeah.
I I also love it when I have
people on my show that teach me something.
It's like I'm getting free training.
So I I sympathize
with you. I know your joy,
especially with the tool that you're already using
and you're learning new stuff about it. Because
one of the things I think that we're
innately bad as humans at
is
we tend to,
especially those of us that are just ravenous
learners, right? We will learn something,
and we get to a point when we're
learning that we tend to taper off our
learning
unless we have a new problem that we
can't solve with it, right, or a new
thing. So
a lot of things that I'm experiencing now
with people when I do trainings is they
have Docker and Compose knowledge,
but they've not really kept up continually over
the last three or four years,
and they need a refresher, right? And that
would almost be like a good course for
someone to do is, you know, Docker Docker
refresher or Kubernetes refresher. That's just
the 2020 features, know, assuming that you knew
it all from 2018 and 2019, just the
latest features of 2020 and 2021.
Because I think we're innate, most of us
are innate, at least I am, really bad
at
going back to a tool, learning new things,
figuring out what things in my files are
now out of date and wrong.
Also, shout out to linters
because that's those those are the things that
will help you know that your old stuff
is old. Linters will often be updated to
the newest spec.
Anyway,
so if we don't have
any specific questions on this one
oh,
so use Compose v two plus the Compose
CLI plugin.
So the Compose CLI plugin is
Compose v two. Okay. So when we when
we're referring to Compose v two, that that
exact word together,
that is Docker's
way of saying we're rebooting Compose into the
Docker command line. And I know it's confusing
confusing because there is a Docker
file
version two and version file version three. We're
not talking about
that when we say now Compose v two.
Docker has chose to brand,
for whatever reason, naming is hard, naming is
like the hardest thing,
they've branded
this new reboot of Compose into the Golang
and inside to the Docker plug in. They're
basically saying this is now
Compose v two
because they're rewriting it from scratch. I would
have preferred them to avoid all confusion and
just call it Compose v four or something.
And one of the reasons they said this,
and it does make sense, because if you
look at the Docker old command line,
if you understand the difference between the file
format and the command line, the old Docker
Compose
version
was perpetual version one. It it's not the
latest version is one dot two nine. So
when they release this new version,
it will,
you know because it's still kind of in
release client.
It is now gonna be the command line
client version two.
What I'm saying in all your files, all
your YAML files now need to just remove
their version format forever. The version YAML file
thing up at the top can just be
blank forever.
No version needed.
And
what that means is is that all the
all the clients,
except Swarm because it's still not been updated.
We don't know when that's gonna get updated,
if ever.
All clients,
all things that consume the Compose file,
those are the things that are now responsible
for adopting
whatever feature you want, like, depends on, okay?
Sorry for the confusion. I know it's a
little much
on on those two things.
Alright. Let's jump to our next demo, and
we can come back to the questions real
quick. Sure.
So the next next thing I wanna talk
about
is
let's do let's find something else here.
What if we
started
Oh, sorry.
It's like Ghost.
Maybe I have
oh, Ghostblog. I love Ghostblog. I use Ghostblog
forever ever since they first launched way long
ago. It's a nonprofit. I'm a big fan
of it. So
not that WordPress is bad, but I love
Ghost. It's also written in Node. Js. So
I use Ghost so that you can just
start up a Ghost server. I think this
is actually all I need. I'm super positive.
But let's say that you have, let's say
that your company has a single Compose file
and you really have them for the front
end developers that are managing the website, right?
Maybe they have the website and then they
have the blog.
So there's a couple people that focus on
the blog infrastructure,
but they also need because maybe it's proxied
on a subdirectory of the main website or
whatever,
you maybe need
to have them all in the same Compose
file. But you don't always need them all
at the same time because maybe there's the
React front end people making the fancy website
and then there's the ghost people just making
the blog or whatever.
So I'm creating a fictitious scenario for why
we need this. So
if we go
I'm sure that there is a web browser
plugin for Versus Code because there's a plugin
for everything. There is a web browser extension.
Do you use one? Do you recommend one?
I don't use one, but I I read
like one of those listicles just yesterday about
these top 10 Versus Code extensions. And one
of them was just bring your web browser
and instead of switching to Chrome for for
debugging. Because I think Versus Code, the the
debugging support in the IDE now supports the
extension that gives you the browser so you
don't have to speak to, like, a real
Chrome or anything. It
seems cool.
Let's see if I still got up my
history.
Yeah.
Anyway, I'm I'm distracted on this, but Oh,
wow. Oh, that's deprecated. Dev tools Chrome. Yeah.
Someone in chat knows knows a good one
that they There's one called browser tab.
You know, it's not got many installs, so
You go wrong.
Browser tab. Oh, browser preview. That's the popular
one. Yeah. I found the listicle.
Real browser preview. Yeah. That's a browser preview,
though.
Anyway,
I'm not sure if that's gonna work, but
because I want a preview of the YAML
file. I just wanted a browser tab, so
we don't to switch. Anyway, it's a browser
tab. You you got a URL bar and
everything. Oh, okay. Okay. I'll try that.
What's the worst thing that could happen? I
know. It's someone's gonna have access. It's like,
please log in with your GitHub account. Oh,
now you have everything.
Browser preview. Alright. Alright.
Yeah. We got another vote for browser preview
in the comments as well. So Oh, nice.
I'm trying to think how I how do
I want my window
I don't want it to be on the
tide there. So
you probably only need the last command. Alright.
So what are we doing? We're doing
oh, I'm gonna go look at the Compose
spec real quick so that I can show
we can sort of correlate these things together.
If I go to the spec,
then
oh, can I do find in here? Will
it will it do find inside
the document?
Probably not.
Let me let me find the actual header.
There we go.
That's what I want.
Profiles
is a new feature in the spec, and
so the spec is really just talking about
how it should work. They give an example
of maybe what it would like look like
in YAML.
And so we have the service at the
top.
Sorry, the services, the main services, then the
service, a single service, and then the profiles
that it's going to be a part of.
So by default, they're all technically sort of
a part of the default profile, but you
can add custom ones,
and so that's what we're gonna do
for Ghost.
And maybe we're going to say,
for profiles, it only needs to be a
part of the blog
profile.
And then everything else
is
a part of just the default. So if
I do a Docker Compose up
oops. No. I didn't want to do that.
If I do a Docker Compose up,
Notice that it still doesn't show well, let's
just make sure I save the file. No
no tricks here.
Okay.
You'll notice that it didn't
doesn't show that ghost blog part. It's not
it's not considering it a part of the
project because I didn't specify that profile.
So if you look at the Docker Compose
command line help, you'll now see
this new option here.
And it's easy to get confused for me,
at least. Confuse the project in the profile.
So we've always had project. Project is the
current scope.
And if you didn't know, when you type
a Docker Compose command, it looks in the
current directory for a file called Docker Compose
YAML, and then it will look up a
directory and up a directory and so on
until it finds one. And it considers that
the project.
You can override that. Obviously, you can have
a different file name if you want and
you specify that with a file name. You
can override which directory to use and you
can actually override the name of the project.
The real quick reason on why you'd ever
wanna do that is if you've ever wanted
to spin up two of the same thing
in the same directory,
that's how you can do it is you
can override the project name and then it
will spin up the same YAML file, but
it will use different container names. It'll add
basically the project name inside the container name.
That's why when when we all probably didn't
realize this, but when you do a Docker
Compose PS,
you're actually seeing the project name first. That's
what the raw code part is. So if
I override that with a dash p, it
will replace that that value with something else
so that they don't conflict. Right? Because we
can't have container names that conflict.
Now, caveat, if you're hard coding your ports,
this will also not work because you'll get
the port confliction.
But the way you get around that in
Dockerfiles is you just don't specify
your published port, and then it will randomly
assign you ports that you can use every
time, and then it'll make sure they never
conflict. So that's a really cool way if
you ever wanna spin something twice without having
to clone it down twice and all that
obnoxious stuff. Alright, so anyway, back
to profile. So profile allows another layer inside
of the project. So I'm in the project
scope. I'm now going to have that profile
part. And so if I do a Docker
Compose
profile
log
up,
it will spin up the ghost. Nice.
This profile, I have to specify with every
command in order to get
the awareness
of those things. Right? So if I don't
if I don't type in dash dash profile,
then it won't know what ghost is because
it won't I think that's true for every
command. Someone in someone in chat might I
don't if Sujay's still around, but somebody in
chat might know wrong know that I'm wrong.
But every command I that I'm aware of
expects that profile there.
So now
notice when I do a Docker Compose ps,
it's well, actually, no. It is listing Go.
So see, I'm already wrong.
What I was gonna say was I have
to use Docker Compose
dash dash profile
blog
ps,
but it's indeed
listing it. So I now that I think
about it, that might have been a recent
change where they added to the p s
command because I've been watching the commits, they
they're these new commands that they're doing, especially
this new feature, they kinda go back and
forth based on feedback. So shout out to
Docker, taking community feedback,
because if you're if you you can jump
on their Slack or in their GitHub issues,
and they're they're they really are taking feedback
and adding new features to Compose based on
feedback. I've had several of my own features,
including adding this healthy
statement inside that line there,
adding that into the new Compose just because
I put in a GitHub issue, and they
marked it for development and put it in.
I didn't have to actually PR it for
them. So
we can do that same thing with something
like Docker Compose.
Let's let's actually see if this works. Docker
Compose top ghost.
Okay. So see that? Maybe they've now done
it so that it knows when I did
the up, I did it on a specific
profile so the other commands
are semi aware of it because it didn't
used to work this way. Docker Compose exec
ghost.
Bash. Let me see. Let me do that.
Okay. So there you go. That's what I
was looking for, is it doesn't see
the service ghost because I have to
do this.
It's a little tedious.
There we go. And now I'm inside of
my container.
So
I tend to use this for either teams
that are all
semi a part of each other's workflow, but
they often don't need to start up everything.
But I often
actually use this more
for
one off
maybe you wanna install all the packages.
Maybe you have a monolithic app and it's
Ruby plus NPM
plus apt get stuff, and you wanna do
a refresh of all the packages or whatever,
and you don't wanna have to shell in
and then type each thing manually. So what
I've seen teams do, a team that I'm
working with is doing this, they do write
little shell scripts to automate all that,
you know, those common developer workflow commands for
their environment,
and then they just make that
something inside of another service. So they might
do
they might just make something
called,
you know,
one off,
you know, or or maybe
update.
Then they'll make it a profile
And then let's say the image we're using
is still ghost.
And
what they really need to do is they're
wanting to apply chain you know, assuming we
got bind mounts here and we're all talking
to the same database, they wanna do maybe
a database schema update or they wanna do
something that's not necessarily in this container, but
they don't wanna shell in and have to
type a bunch of commands. So then they
can type here
command,
you know,
whatever.
I have to get install ghost. So, yeah,
maybe maybe
curl. Right?
So they could do this. Now
what that does that what that means is
is
when they're in their project,
when they just do a normal Docker Compose
up,
it's never gonna try to run that service.
Right? That service is,
by default, will not run because it's not
in a default profile.
So the you know, and default profile means
basically everything that's not listed as a profile.
And then when I wanna do a run
a one off,
one of the neat things about this feature
is that it knows if I wanna do
a run command
or an up command on something and I
specify it directly,
I don't have to list the profile name.
So I can do something like Docker Compose
up
or just even just run
what do I call it? Update.
So
that was, like, a really short command, Docker
Compose run update. And, essentially, what I'm turning
this into is a tool for utility commands
that I don't wanna have to remember the
whole long command that I wanna do, like
a schema update or scan
with
Snyk or Trivy inside of my image and
looking for all of my vulnerabilities. Maybe you
don't wanna have to remember all those commands.
So now
all you really need is an image. It
doesn't really matter what image you use. It
just needs to be the one you wanna
run the tool in. Yep. And then you
can override with that command right there, and
then it does this actually doesn't matter what
profile you call it because we're never going
to specify that profile. In this case, we're
only gonna run that particular
service by name when we wanna do something.
So you might have one that says schema
update and
another service here that says apt get update
or something. And it just it saves you
keystrokes, and it honestly, what it will do
for your dev team is create a standard
around how they do these things.
And you can even because you can sort
of make this command really ugly, you can
avoid shell scripts here as long as you
don't have too much complexity by just doing
it in the YAML. And now your YAML
becomes that single
make file universal
automation tool for local dev. Okay. So just
to clarify, like, the existence of the profile
is key to move it from the default
profile. I mean, and if you run a
Docker Compose up right now, we will not
get an update.
Is that correct?
Say that again. If we run Docker Compose
up, we shouldn't see the update container run.
Right. Because the existence of the profile list
means that it's removed from, like, any sort
of default profile context.
And we also did get a comment from
in the chat saying that you can use
Compose underscore profiles environment variable.
He's always adding value to my streams.
Thanks, man. You're my So
that's a great that's a great point. You
might even have some developer documentation that says,
if you're on this team or if you're
working on this,
just set this profile value and then all
things will be fine. Right?
I'm
assuming you can use dot ENV for that
or well, wait. Dot ENV goes into the
Compose file. It's not used by the Compose
CLI.
Not sure if that's true. Anyway,
Compose can consume a dot ENV file if
you wanna set environment variables there so you
don't have to remember every time in your
shell to set it. But,
yeah, in fact, there's a whole webpage on
environment variables that the Docker Compose command line
can accept, including the profile,
the Docker engine to connect to, like all
there's a lot of things you can do
there and, yeah, Compose Profiles. Great tip. Awesome.
Yeah. Those profiles are a long overdue feature
that would just remove an entire class of
makefails that I've been adding to all my
projects over the years. Like, they can just
disappear now because I can have profiles for
one off tasks and different sets of containers
that I need for different purposes.
Particularly CI is a really good one where
I may wanna run different sets of tests
and use profiles to be able to kinda
orchestrate them in a pretty clean way. So
Yeah. And
if someone's thinking about, well, when can I
use this? Because,
you know, RC, it's it's Release Client, right,
so this new tool isn't truly GA,
you can still do all of this with
the old
I may not be speaking out of turn,
but if I do Docker dash Compose
because the old Compose tool
uses
oh, no. It's not profile.
Oh, there it is. It's
not in alphabetical order. Because
what I was getting ready to say is
that the profile is a Compose spec feature,
not a well, it's technically a CLI feature
combined with this spec feature, you could argue
it either way. But what I was gonna
say is that the old I believe that
the old Compose
traditional Docker
Compose traditional tool,
I believe that that uses and supports this
profile feature, and they I think they've had
that for over a year. If we go
back in the releases of the Compose
Everybody Knows,
they converted to the they updated
to the Compose spec as their file format
at least over a year ago.
And so those of you that are not
yet ready to either run a release client
or you maybe don't have Docker Desktop and
you don't wanna use this release client tool
yet because you're worried about bugs or whatever,
I would say, you know, the Compose you
have now, as long as it's up to
date, supports
a lot of these things. What it doesn't
support is some of the new command line,
like, l s command, right, the new the
new by the way, we can we can
actually do that because now that we have
a project.
You'll you'll see that it it would, yeah,
it would list and this is across my
entire daemon, right, like I was saying. So
if it's five other if you got five
other directories where you're running stuff, you'll see
all of them listed by their project name.
If I were to do
a Docker since we didn't do any ports,
this actually should work. If I do a
Docker Compose,
project? No.
Project name?
Project name. It's also dash p, but I
like the
name in there for everybody so they know
what I'm doing. So I just spun up
the whole state same thing that we just
did in a duplicate
environment, but it's going if I had ports
assigned, it it it would conflict, but we
don't have ports right now. So now I
can do a Docker Compose LS and we
can see both of those running.
Yeah. I think we need to open an
issue against the Compose CLI. So does it
list the directory, the Compose files in? Because
Oh. Because that's just two projects for me
and I just have no idea where those
lived. I would Yeah. Or like yeah. Like
the the either relative path or these maybe
just the full path to where to the
Compose file that it used for that project.
Right? Yeah. Because because right that's that's the
problem right now is
come from. Yeah. Yeah.
Because I customize it. Now, let me go
let me just real quick off screen look
at the Docker dashboard and see if it
actually
because they've been taking a lot of feedback
on the GUI as well, and those of
us that have been trying to use it
are saying, hey. We need this. We need
that.
So, no, I don't see it showing me
an indication of which Compose file. So that's
a great idea.
I wouldn't be surprised if that was already
in there.
Or almost like Docker Compose
info,
right, that does sort of investigation.
Oh, you know what? I wonder if
convert I wonder if convert lists it.
Convert is a little bit of a new
thing.
No. It doesn't.
Convert is a a kind of a new
command.
Basically, what it does is it ingests whatever
you're giving it and then spits out a
consolidated
YAML of what it's going to use.
So, like, for example, I don't specify a
network in our YAML because I just use
the default, but this is literal.
Yeah. So this is kind of like
what Docker Docker Compose
config,
I think, used to be. So if we
did Docker dash Compose
config, one of the things that it would
do
is it would spit out
oh, and you see how it it automatically,
in that old command line, it would spit
out a version. It would assume version three
dot nine the latest because I didn't specify
one.
So it's a little bit like that old
tool,
but
it also has other options that are interesting.
So if you look at the help of
it,
it will help you list out things in
a little bit different format.
It's a it's a little bit weird to
use, but just if you just bear with
me for a second. Docker Compose convert services
will just list my services.
Docker Compose can convert volumes, which I don't
have any.
So if I do profiles
so this might be a part of not
that we're trying to run Bash scripts here,
but if you wanted to wrap this in
other commands,
this is kinda one of those things where
this would be handy to just spit out
the information I need in order to form,
an automated way, other Docker Compose commands. So
maybe if you're using Docker Compose in CI
and you wanna
you wanna find
all the services and then check them all
or do something like that in an automated
way, you could use these as automated
responses in command lines. But that's that's really
the only reason I can think of using
it that way. But wonder if the Compose
LS can't list the directories because, I mean,
there's no primitive of Compose project, right? I
mean, maybe it's just parsing the names of
the containers and going, you look like a
Compose project, and that's all it really knows.
Right. True. Because a lot of this is
dealing with labels, right? So if
oh, well, I think I have to do
You may have to do a container inspect
or something. Yeah.
A lot of people there's not actually a
lot of magic to Compose, really. It's just
really talking to the Docker command line or
Docker c l not to the CLI, but
the to the API, the Docker engine,
and
adding labels
for all of the things it needs to
do to keep track of.
So you will see Rawkode. There we go.
Right. Yeah.
And that is actually the
and I think I mentioned this earlier, but
I wanna reiterate, you can use both command
lines back and forth. They're designed to be
compatible with each other, so you can use
a Docker Compose up with the dashed old
version and then a Docker Compose down with
the new version,
so they're completely
compatible with each other because they're really just
using, for the most part, these same labels
to identify
the services and the volumes and networks and
all that stuff that it needs to know.
So it's not like there's a database somewhere
or some Compose
API that's running as a daemon, and
storage inside of Docker, really, to keep Compose
specific things. So it just uses the same
labels like we would use in a Kubernetes
cluster, really,
to do that work. If you're a Swarm
of fans, Swarm actually uses, for the stacks,
that stack feature really only uses service labels
to organize
all the objects
for stacks. So that's actually how Swarm works
as well. It uses
different labels. These are actually container labels. In
Swarm, it uses
different object labels for for the stack to
work. But anyway, it's all just metadata. Metadata
all the way down.
Alright. What else we got, people?
Someone else about security. That's a whole separate
topic. Yeah. Well, you just asked if we
covered any security practices
here. I mean, does security come into play?
I mean, we're still saying Compose is a
tool for local development rather than production.
So
do we leave security at at the other
side of the door for that? Yeah. Because
because, again, yeah, like you're saying, like, I
don't advocate even though you can technically use
Compose on a server for production,
I don't I don't ever really advocate its
use. I feel like in
most cases, we've all moved beyond it.
That being said, with the new Docker Compose
deploy, which we didn't even talk about today,
but, you know, maybe some other day,
have you had people on your show before
to talk about the deploy, the AC the
ECS and ACI stuff? No. I know you've
had some Docker people on recently, so I
didn't know if you
because Docker Compose
there's not a deploy. Right? Yeah. No. It's
they haven't changed it. Alright. Haven't used this
in a few months. So Docker Compose up,
and I can I can point it at
a
ECS cluster or an ACI instance or other
other
types of
Docker
plug
connections? I don't know how you should describe
it. Does that coupling of deployment with, like,
your database and your app not give you
the fear, though? Like, I I I can't
see a world where I'd want to use
that. I think that's where I get Well,
I think the argument that so the reason
that Docker's adding all these is that they
feel like there's still a really big gap,
and you'll see this with Docker Desktop with
the new dev
workspaces or dev
what are they called? Have to look it
up already. Dev environments is what they're calling
it, which, like, a different topic altogether. But
what we're seeing is that Docker is trying
to solve developer problems, not production problems. Right?
So I would argue that this Docker Compose
up towards ECS or ACI or, you know,
I've been asking them to do a Digital
Ocean one and
some of the other non major clouds.
Know that they would like to do a
Google one as well.
They argue that maybe this is really for
the one person shops, right, where you're just
like the solo DevOps person and you
simply can't use those other tools because of
their complexity and you don't have enough time,
and so this is good enough.
And
also, a lot of times, developers need to
share what they're working on or just literally
just test something on a server somewhere that's
outside their machine. I actually was just working
with a developer yesterday
that his he had a '20 '18 MacBook,
and he couldn't spin up in Docker locally
his the
the environment that he needed to test the
app because it required
16 gig of RAM for everything to work
and to run all the r specs because
there was, like, 90,000 r specs or something.
So
they needed a server to run it on,
and there's not really any deep, easy integration
in a lot of these tools to just
say, hey, create me an instance on the
cloud, put my stuff on it, run it
there for a minute. And I think that's
what they're doing. Now, will people use that
for production? Sure.
People always use dev tooling for production when
they shouldn't. But I think there's a I
think there's room, right? There's room for us
to have this tooling. What I do hope
is that they communicate
well about
the the goal and intent of these tools,
not, hey. Look. We have this new way
to deploy ECS. You should totally use this
all day for production. Right?
Because they don't always like, the messaging is
sometimes lost in, hey. Look at the new
thing we did, and people assume that you
say, oh, well, said ECS, so you must
mean your production workflows.
Yeah. I hadn't really thought about it through
that lens. But, you know, people if you're
using managed services for one from AWS and
you just need to get your dev environment
into that environment, then that's actually a really
good way of of doing it. And I
just hadn't really given that a lot of
thought. Yeah. But maybe that would work. I
mean, still a whole bunch of other concerns
around the authorization and the IAM policies to
speak to those managed overseas.
For a very crude development environment that's in
the cloud, yeah. Okay. Yeah. That would work.
Think for the same thing, like, the same
what was the same thing was happening with
Docker Machine. People were using Docker Machine to
spin up production servers.
And I and I probably was quoted,
and you probably could have found a video
of me from somewhere
circa 2018
saying, hey, look, because I appeal to the
solo DevOps, to the solo developer, right? Whenever
I do a talk at a big conference,
I always try to get a one of
the things I do survey is how many
people here are responsible for their DevOps, and
they're the only one
that is doing that in the team, essentially
what I call SoloDevOps.
A quarter of the room raises their hands,
right? So there's this huge need that's not
the majority, but an untapped need for
we don't need at scale. In fact, if
I were to put on a t shirt
from Pulp Fiction that says, say at scale
one more time, the the famous line
I'm forgetting his name now. Samuel L. Jackson's
character.
He says,
something one more time, and it's to say
at scale one more time on the Internet
because there's definitely a lot of tools out
there that are focused on large infrastructure,
hundreds or thousands of containers, but there are
definitely lots of teams where there's one person,
maybe two,
they need a dozen servers, maybe 20 servers,
and they just
don't need the inherent complexity that comes with
implementing Terraform, Ansible,
Argo CD, GitHub Actions, and this huge tech
stack for
I want to run some containers on servers
for a while.
So I appeal to those people. Yeah.
Okay.
We've
ran a little bit over, so I'm gonna
pop us back over to here. Sorry. Do
you have anything else you want to shore
shore?
No. That's it. I mean, we could talk
forever, so we have to cut it off
at some point. Yeah. I'll leave you with
the I'm here to answer questions, so if
people have more questions, you know. Yeah. We'll
we'll take one more question. If any more
slip in, we'll do our best to answer
them. But
asked, is this still in beta, the ECS
thing?
Because he says that he has to enable
some sort of beta Docker thingy to get
that to work. Is that the case?
I don't know. If Sujay's still in the
chat, he might know more.
I would say,
as far as I know,
it is still
pre general
availability,
pre GA, prerelease.
I am
assuming that they're tying the
version, because right now we're on, like, RC
something of the actual Docker Compose command line
tool, and that is that plugin is what's
needed in order to deploy to these contexts.
And we didn't get into context, but that's
what we're talking
You change your context from your local Docker
engine to ECS or to ACI,
and then you can use Docker Compose up
to deploy to those contexts,
similar to Kubernetes Kube control context.
And as I'm assuming that they're tying those
features to the
version of the Compose CLI since they're bundled
in with it. And since it is not
GA, I will assume that they are also
not GA. But that's a lot of assumptions.
Don't quote me on that.
Alright. Well, that was an awesome feature pad
session. It was really good to get a
look at that and just see how the
profiles work and see how cool that Compose
CLI is is coming along. I'm really excited
with that, and I'm looking forward to actually,
like I said, removing a whole bunch of
make files in Bash scripts. I have so
many of them scattered across so many projects
that that one simple
profile feature just removes all. That's really exciting
to me. It's
yeah. I have the same way in the
same way I was using something called Docker
app, which is really not anymore anymore a
thing. They're they're deprecating that as well. But
there was this idea for a while about
formalizing
a lot of the the tooling and versioning
around Compose files into something that was called
Docker App. And one the offshoots of that
is that it could kinda dynamically create
Compose files on the fly from other templates,
and this profile thing basically saves me from
all of that. It saves me from having
to
try to wrap around that.
Another Docker captain was actually working on all
of that stuff too, trying to formalize a
tool that would allow us to
basically solve the templating needs of complex teams
that need to use Compose for development environments,
but not always spin everything up all the
time. And, yeah, that profile feature, definitely. You
know, I'm sure there's more things we could
add to it,
but I think that really helps. I I
should do a plug for you and my
you and me as well. For those of
you that are in chat, if you didn't
get your questions answered, we both have Discords.
So, you know, I'm in his Discord. I
think he's in mine. I'm not sure.
So just find us in Discord if you
have questions later or on Twitter. We're both
on Twitter. If we don't get your questions
answered, don't worry. We're not going anywhere.
Because, you know,
we live on the Internet, so I'm I'm
available after this live show. Yeah. We're both
very active on Twitter. Our handles are on
the screen. We both do have Discords. We're
active there too. And in fact, we pulled
through a lot of your announcements into our
channel as well. So
sharing sharing the the love and the knowledge
as much as we can. So
alright, Brent. I to a I need to
have a zap for you. I need to
figure that out later. Yeah. Because I'd love
to have that more of that stuff in
some of my Twitter
channels too, so we'll talk about that later.
Awesome. Well, thank you so much for joining
me today, for guiding us through this. Just
so much value in the conversation as well.
You just shared so much insights there about
how people are using this tool. Definitely go
check out Brett's courses.
Keep learning, and thank you again. Brett, have
a wonderful day, and I'll I'll see you
soon.
Yeah. See you all.